bonsoir nous sommes le lundi 18 janvier
merci de nous retrouver pour cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 le journal comme
chaque jour votre information locale
entouré de nos invités mais aussi des
journalistes de la rédaction on commence
tout de suite avec les titres de cette
édition mobilisation pour le futur du
site de thiverval grignon samedi un
collectif pour l'avenir de ce site s'est
rassemblé 300 personnes ont manifesté
pour sauvegarder ce lieu et ce projet de
s'opposer au projet privé dont la
possible installation du camp de base du
psg elancourt misent sur le numérique la
ville forme ces enseignants aux
nouvelles technologies dans le cadre de
la réforme scolaire du temps d'activités
partagées
reportage à suivre enfin l'acteur claude
brasseur à l'espace coluche de plaisir
samedi soir il incarnait georges
clemenceau dans la colère du tigre nous
l'avons rencontré pour voir ce journal
cette information une foire aux
conserves a été organisé ce week-end par
le secours populaire dans les yvelines
pour cette onzième édition secours
populaire s'est associée avec plusieurs
magasins carrefour du département
objectif de l'opération
les industriels se sont engagés à
reverser 7% de leur chiffre d'affaires
obtenus sur les boîtes de conserve
les sommes collectées ont participé à
favoriser l'organisation des journées
les oubliés des vacances pour rappel le
secours populaire est actuellement sur
le plan alimentaire 7000 personnes du
département et dans le cadre de la loi
de finances rectificative du 29 décembre
2015 saint quentin en yvelines va
profiter d'une forte diminution de la
taxe perçue à l'occasion de la
construction de la reconstruction ou de
l'agrandissement des locaux à usage de
bureaux anciennement redevance pour
création de bureaux
cette redevance sera désormais sur saint
quentin en yvelines de 50 euros le m² de
bureaux au lieu des 230 5
initialement prévu l'agglomération qui
dispose d'une surface de 1 5 million de
mètres carrés de bureaux bénéficiera
ainsi d'une position plus avantageuse
que paris ou des communes du département
des hauts-de-seine dont les taxes
demeurent plus élevés et nous
accueillons ce soir en plateau thiery
doléances responsable local d'europe
écologie les verts attire l'agrion
bonsoir et bienvenue en plateau et
jean-vincent du collectif pour le futur
du site de grignon alors merci monsieur
d'avoir d'avoir répondu à notre
invitation
effectivement l'avenir du site de
thiverval grignon inquiète samedi matin
plusieurs associations se sont réunies
pour manifester contre le départ du site
de l'école agroparistech la vente du
domaine est également son éventuel
rachat par un acteur privé parmi
lesquelles le psg nous en parlerons avec
vous messieurs dans quelques instants
juste après ce reportage les images sont
signés mélanie poté tous mobilisés pour
sauver grignon samedi plus de 300
personnes riverains associatifs et
politiques se sont rassemblés pour cette
première manifestation contre le projet
de vente 490 hectares de terres
agricoles un parc mais aussi un château
de style louis xiii appartenant à
l'école d'ingénieurs agro paris tech
pour moi c'est vraiment important de
gagner de garder craignent le patrimoine
français et d'en faire quelque chose
après que les élèves sont partis
donc c'est vraiment important de trouver
un projet qui convient le site qui est
un site qui doit être protégé puisqu'il
est vraiment c'est vraiment ainsi très
beau et très très important pour le
patrimoine français au mois de mars 2015
l'école a décidé de partir pour le
campus paris saclay l'état est
propriétaire du lieu et des
investisseurs privés se montrent
intéressés pour l'investir dont le club
de football du paris saint germain
il pourrait installer son nouveau camp
de base à grignon avec entre autres un
stade de 5000 classe et 18 terrains de
football
le groupe français l'oréal est lui aussi
intéressé pas du psg c'est qu'ils
risquent de dénaturer l'environnement
c'est ça qui nous gêne mais bon qui soit
qatari ou tu sais pas c'est pas ça le
problème
c'est un psg c'est un acheteur ennuyeux
parce qu ils détériorent l'oréal ça
serait mieux mais je sais pas ce qu'il
en ferait selon le collectif c'est une
perte importante pour le patrimoine
scientifique français à la place il met
en avant son projet de création d'un
centre international des changes pour
l'agriculture et l'environnement de
demain c'est surtout lé
le centre intéressante agronomique le
centre au lieu de 220 de formation et de
recherche
des résultats qui de sont positifs ils
sont acculés c7 se passer de
scientifiques qui devraient faire
abandonner alors que les besoins sont
énormes
une pétition a été lancée par le
collectif elle a déjà rassemblé près de
9000 signatures et sera prochainement
envoyé au ministre de l'agriculture
stéphane le foll pour le sensibiliser à
cette affaire alors messieurs on l'a
entendue dans le sujet ça fait depuis
mars 2000 tient ce que paris tech a
annoncé son départ
la mobilisation commence simplement
maintenant pourquoi en fait la
mobilisation
commencent à converger aujourd'hui il ya
eu plusieurs acteurs depuis quelques
années déjà qui se sont intéressés aux
sur le sujet les associations locales et
aussi
nous au conseil régional d'île de france
europe écologie les verts avons déjà
fait des actions puisque le conseil
régional a déjà investi beaucoup
d'argent pour la recherche pour les
locaux je pense notamment au programme
bio gère on en a parlé tout à l'heure
et puis des logements sociaux donc sont
là aujourd'hui ce qu'on a ce qu'on a vu
là samedi c'est la convergence de toutes
les associations qui s'intéressait déjà
sur le sujet depuis fort longtemps
j'entends vous vous êtes par faire
partie du collectif pour l avenir pour
le futur du site de grignon il ya une
pétition également acquis est lancé on
l'a entendue dans le reportage vous avez
mobilisé toutes les associations pour
justement cette matinée de samedi puis
tout à fait vous conte soir d'avoir à
tout le monde ne pouvait pas imaginer
que la privatisation du domaine et le
parquet les laboratoires ils disent nous
vient de parler notre interlocuteur et
donc c'est complètement scandalisés
étonné que c'est apparemment réveillé
tardivement mais semble-t-il assez
efficacement cette première
manifestation qui n'est qu'une première
manifestation et on est assez scandalisé
dans vue d'envisager que tel patrimoine
historique et écologique et scientifique
soit bradé par nos plus hautes autorités
minister d'agriculture et autres ce qui
serait ce qu on a beaucoup entendu
pareille ce moment de l'installation de
sites du paris saint germain c'est
vraiment le sujet tiers on a fait par
les ajustements de ce site à naughty dog
réunion dans les médias mais comme on a
pu voir dans le dossier je n'ai pas
vraiment le seul problème c'était pas le
mini prenons que l'on revendique parce
que ce n'est pas encore signé n'y a pas
encore de source n'y a pas d'information
voilà ci ne sont que des spéculations
par rapport à ça c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui on n'a pas d'information
officielle sur le devenir du site à qui
il sera vendu s'il sera vendu ou pas on
n'a que des bruits et c'est aussi ça
qu'on voulait mettre en avant c'est que
ce sitcom
jean l'a rappelé c'est vraiment un
patrimoine scientifique inestimable ça
fait plus de deux cents ans que c'est un
centre de recherche agronomique
c'est également un centre reconnu
mondialement pour sa richesse géologique
sur l'étude de l'impact du climat sur la
biodiversité qui est vraiment un sujet
actuel aujourd'hui on a eu la coop 21 il
ya quelques semaines en france qui a
rappelé ce sujet là et c'est donc un
patrimoine d'état donc un patrimoine
commun et ce que nous souhaiterions
c'est que il est vraiment une réflexion
avec tous les acteurs possibles pour
l'avenir de société qui ne soit pas
vendu à des intérêts privés
parce que si on revient vraiment sur le
sujet en fait le la l'école
agroparistech va déménager dont le
campus de paris saclay elle veut se
rapprocher voilà deux se confia ce qui
peut sembler logique peut-être voilà
enfin compréhensible dans tous les cas
mais le problème c'est que ça va être
dommageable à gryon mais pas seulement
il ya des enjeux qui sont plus
importants que ça le déménagement
d'agroparistech tout cas été votée comme
vous le rappeliez au par le conseil
d'administration au mois de mars dernier
un déménagement prévu pour 2019
maintenant est ce que c'est une bonne
chose
bon ça a été actée nous on pense que
concentrer toutes les activités sur
saclay et qui risque même de mettre des
chercheurs en agronomie un peu hors sol
parce que les terres il y en a pas
beaucoup à saclay pour les études ce
n'est pas une bonne chose mais le débat
s'est surtout de comment faire pour que
le site de grignon reste dans le giron
de l'état et dans le bien commun pour
les recherches actuelles et futures
puisqu'on ne sait pas ce qu'on peut
découvrir encore ce qui vous effraient
c'est vraiment laid les travaux qui
peuvent peut-être fait sur ce site
mais là je reviens un peu en arrière la
tuerie de lundi que c'était définitif là
le départ à saclay en fait le sacré
n'est pas encore financés à l'eau après
on pourrait détailler mais je crois
qu'on n'a pas le temps donc il y aura
encore un vote quand les le projet
architectural et financier sera bouclé
pour que le conseil des ministres à sion
se prononcent à nouveau sur le progrès
j'ai donc on ne peut pas anticiper ça
sera dans plus d'un ans ce vote
définitif
alors le en attendant il ya des risques
importants temps plus que l'état garde
le plus grand secret sur cette vente qui
semble s'orienter vers le privé comme
vous avez pu avoir des influences alors
que comme le dit thierry delord ce qui
est important c'est que ça reste un bien
commun public à la disposition si vous
craignez vous cette lignée des
transformations sur ce site là la façon
vraiment pourquoi le collectif à le
devenir des lotissements immobilier sis
et si jamais c'était
centre d'entraînement sportif y aurait
d'après ce qu'on apprend un stade de
5000 places un parking de 1000 places 20
terrains de football sur un terrain de
foot c'est presque un hectare et il est
en fait le site un vallon qui est sur le
plan botanique paysage est extrêmement
précieux et rare pendant pour cette
région de l'ouest parisien
c'est peut-être un des derniers poumons
vraiment naturel qui se trouvent dans
l'ouest parisien
alors on a parlé de la car un peu de la
carrière sa lumière qui correspond un
site géologique mondialement connu il ya
aussi sur le versant on me dit ce qu'on
appelle une duc ces reliques via des bus
une zone de buis qui date d'avant la
dernière glaciation
enfin la forêt elle même est composée
d'espèces variées qui existe depuis
comme l'origine du parc et plusieurs
centaines sans parler du château et sans
parler des laboratoires il ya plus de
400 personnes qui travaillent dont une
grande partie de chercheurs et de
techniciens états unis ont des problèmes
il ya différents environnements et la
drôle et légal prévoit de l'écosystème
géologique l'établissement participé
également la recherche donc sur
l'agriculture l'environnement et son
déménagement on n'est pas cohérent selon
vous par rapport aux objectifs de
l'accord 21 qui a été annoncé par le
gouvernement
on a une richesse de scientifiques qui
aide les chercheurs à cet endroit là on
va pas déplacé plusieurs centaines de
mètres de terre en souterrain à saclay
pour qui vont accompagner les chercheurs
donc si ça va dans le giron privé pour
bien comprendre les sur cette école ils
font vraiment des recherches sur les
sols et c'est utiliser oui d'ailleurs ça
fait plus de deux cents ans qu'il ya un
suivi sur la qualité d'être des salles
et même ce patrimoine là pourraient
disparaître et c'est une autre richesse
très importante scientifique écologie
les verts vous avez fait appel justement
au gouvernement ou une star au ministre
de l'agriculture sur ce sujet oui la
semaine dernière emmanuel coste la
secrétaire nationale qui par ailleurs
présidente du groupe au conseil régional
ile de france a envoyé un courrier à
stéphane le foll pour l'alerter sur ce
sujet et
créer les conditions d'une réflexion un
peu plus large pour que l'avenir de ce
site ne soit pas décidée par quelques
personnes mais que tout les acteurs
concernés puissent se mettre autour de
la table et trouver la meilleure
solution
toujours pas toujours pas ce que vous
attendez gens ensemble
le collectif que vous attendez du site
vous attend une réponse du gouvernement
que ce soit quoi est-ce que vous avez un
projet aussi justement pour ce site
devant je me suis dit que il ya les
partenaires actuels qui ceux qui se sont
manifestés au cours de la marche samedi
sont plus larges que windows est appelé
hier ça soit lui même commence à y avoir
un grand nombre d'associations soit 2 se
préoccupe de patrimoine de milieux
naturels et des randonneurs ces dix
cyclistes
c'est très large le projet qu'on est en
train d'élaborer à leur faut qu'on
trouve des financements pour ça et on va
faire une étude approfondie
c'est comment utiliser les locaux
édition qui sont très vastes
correspondent à un dizième
investissements récents de l'état et de
la situation de la recherche agronomique
qui refuse de se donner aucune
indication sur le futur donc il faut que
ces investissements la déficience
ce qu'on souhaite être un centre
international sur l'agroécologie qui
serait dans le prolongement de la cap 21
et qui permettrait de d'élargir et de
prolonger les recherches et de s'ouvrir
sur une dimension diffusion
vulgarisation on pourrait parler d'une
sorte de cité de l'agronomie comme une
cité des sciences à la villette sa
nombreuse les investissements dans
l'état du coup oui il ya d'une fondation
et d'autres sources qu'eux on se propose
de commenc de race
vous avez fait donc une pétition vous
attendait justement d'avoir dix mille
votes pour l'instant à peu près de 9000
pour avoir aussi une réponse du ministre
ou son rêve d'aller faire d'autres
actions prochainement
oui alors il ya plusieurs autres actions
qui sont prévus le déjà une marche la
gela celle de samedi à l'école la ferme
extérieur à l'entrée de l'école donc
c'était environ un kilomètre on prévoit
une marge beaucoup plus la faune autour
des murs de l'école qui fonçait de
kilomètres ça vous fera peut-être pas
les 7 km et puis à d'autres événements
qui sont prévues qui on va se structurer
beaucoup plus puisque vos commentaires
une sorte de consortium entre les
différentes associations et groupements
concernés qu'ils avaient aussi des
appuis des élus justement du territoire
local
on a peut-être un appui objectif en la
personne de notre député monsieur david
douillet qui lui suit le dossier depuis
très longtemps et préférer une
installation du paris saint germain
poissy ce qui permettrait temporairement
d'arrêter peut-être la vente du site de
grignon et puis de réfléchir à d'autres
solutions
on l'a d'ailleurs interpellé on lui a
envoyé un courrier ce matin donc il n'a
pas encore reçu sur le sujet vous
proposez a également un projet vous
l'avez à des choses voilà que voudrait
mettre en avant par rapport au
gouvernement où ce serait vraiment une
réflexion collective
la spécificité de l'engagement d'un
collectif c'est que chacun peut apporter
sa pierre donc tous les que le collectif
des scientifiques des associations
locales ont déjà engagé le travail
nous on a fait un travail un peu plus
institutionnel on va dire à côté donc on
va continuer à travailler en synergie et
puis en espérant aller
trouver une solution ensemble concertée
pour que ce site exceptionnel reste la
propriété de l'état donc notre propriété
merci merci beaucoup monsieur adepte
revenus soient pas tous et d'avoir
répondu à nos questions nous suivrons
bien sûr cette actualité sien depuis la
rentrée scolaire 2014 la réforme à des
rythmes scolaires permet aux élèves de
classes élémentaires de bénéficier
gratuitement d'activités variées lors de
leurs temps d'activités périscolaires la
ville d'elancourt a choisi pour
développer l'éducatif le support
numérique
regardez ce reportage de sephora namani
et william l développer la mémoire la
créativité le vivre ensemble et la
confiance en soi chez l'enfant par
l'outil numérique
c'est ce que propose la ville
d'elancourt pour ces temps d'activités
périscolaires 14 de séance d'une heure
et demie pour se familiariser avec le
tableau numérique tehani savoir ils
apprennent à manier de tennie le
logiciel qui activent inspire qui est
utilisé par les enseignants aussi savoir
parmi deux dates francs parce que vu que
les étés les en classe et en classe ils
n'ont pas cette facilité d'aller
directement au tableau fouiller un peu
ici peuvent eux ils peuvent eux se
permettre parce que je vais pas leur
noté ou leur donner des vins ne l'auront
fait pas du travail on en apprend que tu
t'en s'amusant sur un tennis affaires de
progresser ma mémoire du cp au cm2 tous
les élèves de la ville d'elancourt sont
équipés d'une tablette
chaque classe dispose d'un tableau
numérique enseignants et animateurs sont
formés aux outils numériques par le
réseau associatif canopée il ya une
logique de continuité éducative vous le
savez à elancourt toutes les classes
baigne dans le numérique les enfants
depuis cinq ans maintenant les tablettes
les tennis et ses outils font partie de
leur vie quotidienne
ce choix parce que les enfants
d'aujourd'hui sont les adultes de demain
qui utiliseront ces outils et que ça
fait partie de leur formation
pendant cette semaine les élèves de ces
ateliers pourront découvrir le tableau
numérique
le stop motion le livre numérique le
montage vidéo et la web radio des
ateliers important pour l encours qui
misent 40% des activités de cete ap
autour du numérique
et les cérémonies des voeux des mairies
continue la cérémonie de voeux de
villepreux était programmée vendredi
dernier au gymnase alain mimoun
le maire de la commune stéphane
mirambeau est revenu à cette occasion
sur l'inauguration du nouveau quartier
de la commune les eaux du moulin plus de
500 logements ont été construits dans ce
secteur et lui a également évoqué
l'entrée de sa commune dans saint
quentin en yvelines
on les écoute il était au micro de
michael almy d'euros il y à beaucoup de
vus ville provient qui se disent tout de
suite qu est ce que ça va nous apporter
en plus mais est-ce que ça va pas
risquer de nous coûter encore plus cher
et il faut qu'on les rassure c'est pour
ça que ce soir j'ai voulu les rassurer
et je crois que d'ailleurs c'est tout
l'objectif de michel laugier
il ne souhaite pas augmenter la pression
fiscale nous savons que ça va être dur
les dotations de l'état seront en berne
aussi pour cette nouvelle structure
nous devons donc gérer au plus juste et
c'est votre rendez vous culturel du
lundi nous recevons ces for a name année
pour sa chronique culturelle bonsoir
sephora vos sorts floral alors ce soir
je viens vous présenter une autre façon
de découvrir les grands lieux
historiques comme le château de
versailles
ces visites guidées qui attire en
majorité touriste française des
étrangers un moyen de rentrer dans
l'intimité du patrimoine français
s'était jamais venu à versailles donc
mon intention valls était de me faufiler
un petit peu dans les choses d'un peu
plus intimiste et j'ai vu début janvier
le reportage sur les appartements de la
reine aussi je crois et dont j'ai dit
j'y vais j'utilise la philologie
française en espagne et pour une
étudiante sur l'histoire et pour nous
c'était un plaisir de voir tout ce qui
est tout ce que nous faisons en cours
tout ce que nous voyons de manière
théorique
ici on est plongé dans le bain sujet
donc c'est un peu émouvant quand même
alors à versailles il existe différents
parcours d'une heure trente
régulièrement renouvelés les groupes
accueille jusqu'à 20 personnes
la visite guidée est menée par un guide
conférencier formé en histoire et en
histoire de l'art en l'occurrence il
s'agissait de sylvain postolle qui nous
initie à l'intimité de marie antoinette
à versailles il nous explique l'intérêt
de ces visites
guidés effectivement quand on vient à
versailles on peut se promener librement
et cependant il est vrai que même avec
les informations qui sont données dans
les salles ou bien encore avec l'aide de
l'audioguide ce n'est toujours peut-être
pas suffisant donc pour aller un peu
plus loin il est vrai que les visites
conférences peuvent apporter d'autres
informations
et puis peut-être aussi répondre plus
précisément aux questions des gens ils
intérêt supplémentaire de ses visites
guidées c'est que sont ouvertes à ce
moment-là des pièces traditionnellement
fermés au public parce qu'il s'agit de
pièces fragiles c'est le cas de la
majorité des pièces de la visite sur
marie antoinette le cas notamment de la
salle des bains et par exemple avec
celle des appartements du roi
vous pourrez justement découvrir la
chapelle royale ou encore l'opéra royal
qui est un très très beau lieu alors
avec ces visites le puits mais que ce
soit un petit peu privilégié un hôte de
choix
c'est ça exactement privilégiés ils ont
vraiment le sentiment d'être bien
encadrer et orienter dans leurs
réflexions
je pensais trouver plus de gens et moins
de formation et en fait on a été très
surpris parce que notre guide nous avons
une plus ce qu'ils me visite guidée
c'est une leçon d'histoire
je le félicite parce que franchement ça
a été pour moi ça a été vraiment toute
une source d'information que je
m'attendais pas du tout ce que
j'apprécie énormément alors en général
les visites sont et autour de grands
personnages historiques mais aussi de
périodes précises où même de mobilier
particulière exactement il s'agit de
visites thématiques ce qui vous permet
d'approfondir vos périodes de
prédilection et de comprendre comment se
déroulait la vie quotidienne ou xviie et
xviiie siècles
alors vous pouvez participer à
différentes visites comme celle montée
autour de l'exposition temporaire le roi
est mort ou bien retracer les grandes
figures historiques celle de louis xiv
napoléon et de gaulle au trianon
d'autres pour visiter les appartements
privés du roi marie antoinette à
versailles les lieux cachés et une sur
la révolution même alors ce sont des
visites qui s'adresse à tout type de
public je pense aux enfants et peut-être
personne leur handicap également tout à
fait oui vraiment le public rassemblé et
éclectique et surtout ses visites comme
vous l'avait bien dit
sont proposés à tous types de personnes
en situation de handicap comme les
personnes malvoyantes et malentendantes
et c'est d'ailleurs tout l'art d'un bon
médiateur que de savoir s'adapter à son
public par définition je dirais selon
moi un d'un os en guide conférencier
c'est bien sûr de posséder les
connaissances qu'ils conviennent mais
surtout d'être capable de les adapter au
public qui est face à soi c'est à dire
et bien de partir du texte scientifique
rédigé par exemple par un conservateur
pour adapter les mots de façon à ce que
ce public soit en mesure de comprendre
et de sortir de la visite en sachant que
vient dans cette pièce il s'est passé
tel événement mais aussi que l'on vivait
de telle manière
voilà et de garder finalement des idées
simples pour ces visites guidées il vous
en coûtera 7 euros de plus que votre
billet d'entrée pour ceux qui ne
bénéficient pas de la gratuité et les
réservations peuvent se faire en ligne
sur le site du château
merci beaucoup à ces fora pourquoi ne
pas découvrir ou redécouvrir le show de
versailles avec des idées c'est une
bonne idée
on vous retrouve mercredi pour un
nouveau numéro de kiosques et vous
puisque vous pouvez nous faire un petit
teasing de quoi se retiennent question
bien sûr et je pense d'ailleurs que les
deux invités vont vous évoquez quelque
chose car nous avons eu la chance de
recevoir vincent de dien également en
plateau nous aurons o'shea qui a
participé à la saison de the voice kid
très bien et bien nous avons commencé
avec impatience ce fort à merci beaucoup
et nous restons dans la culture claude
brasseur était à plaisir samedi soir
pour une nouvelle représentation de la
colère du tigre dans la peau d'un
clemenceau vieillissant le comédien fait
face un autre géant de son époque claude
monet nous avons eu la chance de le
rencontrer regarder
claude monet figure de l'impressionnisme
face à georges clemenceau surnome il
perd la victoire en raison de son action
pendant la guerre deux figures du début
du xxème siècle deux amis qui en 1923 se
retrouvaient s'affrontent monde est
confronté à la cécité bientôt aveugle
qui n'osent avouer qu'il ne pourra
terminer ses nymphéas et honorer la
promesse faite à clemenceau d'exposer au
musée de l'orangerie sont deux hommes
qui qui qui qui s'engueulent mais
vraiment très très fort et qui en même
temps ça dort le conte fée a réellement
existé tout ce qui se passe au cours de
la pièce fait est historique
n'oublions molière en 2015 claude
brasseur était sur les planches de
l'espace coluche à plaisir le week-end
dernier après plus de 200
représentations le comédien ressent le
même plaisir à retrouver ce personnage
c'est surtout très agréable de le faire
au théâtre parce que justement
contrairement au cinéma au théâtre on
peut faire des progrès au cinéma on peut
pas faire de progrès une fois que c'est
fait c'est fait bon comme les du comme
disait jouvet au teatro joue au cinéma
on a joué je pense que le cinéma c'est
pas notre métier c'est le g toute note
bande quand on est au conservatoire tout
notre bande on ne rêvait que de terre
s'est produit tout faire du cinéma ça ne
nous intéressait pas c'est très amusant
le cinéma mais c'est un métier de
technicien de deux acteurs peuvent à
meerab le mans jouer la comédie
si c'est mal filmé et mal monté on a
l'air de cons au cinéma claude bras se
retrouvera néanmoins franck dubosc cet
été pour le troisième volet de la
comédie familiale camping
la tournée se poursuit pour la colère du
tigre une pièce qui trouve d'ailleurs un
écho bien particulier dans l'actualité
on en aurait bien besoin aujourd'hui
d'un ménage comme saada dans la
politique d'un homme intègre
rien ne lui appartenait et là il a tout
sacrifié pour pour la france et c'est
bientôt la fin de cette édition mais
juste avant de nous dire au revoir cette
information vous l'avez peut-être vu
dimanche matin la neige est tombée dans
les yvelines se sont que quelques
flocons on le voit ici sur ces images
tournées à versailles le dimanche matin
très tôt
mais cette semaine ne vous inquiétez pas
si les températures seront très basses
et descendant sous les zéro degré pas
d'autres épisodes neigeux sont à prévoir
il est inutile de s'inquiéter de
s'inquiéter ni même de sortir les
chaînes et c'est maintenant la fin de
cette édition je vous remercie de nous
avoir suivis tout de suite vous avez
rendez vous avec michael et demi d'euros
pour le 7-8 sports au programme de la
course du vélo mais surtout du rugby
quant à moi je vous retrouve demain pour
un nouveau numéro du 7 8 le journal je
vous souhaite donc une très bonne soirée